depuis plus de 200 ans la demeure
appartient à la famille d'edward verdun
pièce maîtresse du parc de ce gîte cette
serre du 19e siècle sélectionnés par la
mission berne edwards et alexia son
épouse avait du mal à y croire on est
très très surpris ravi fier aussi que
notre projet soit soit porté par par
cette fondation c'est ça va permettre de
préserver ce chef-d'oeuvre de faire une
ride 19e siècle dans les années 1870 ont
cultivé ici plantes et légumes
c'est une bio pelletier qui a été
fabriqué à orléans avec une ferronnerie
assez remarquable
rongé par la rouille barreau brisées ou
dessoudé la serre horticole du château
est aujourd'hui en péril son
propriétaire edwards ne l'a jamais
connue en état de fonctionnement
quand j'étais petit il y avait encore
quelques carreaux qui subsistait
nous si vous voulez le l'idée générale
de ce loto du patrimoine c'est de
refaire cette serre à l'identique de
respecter le bâtiment au maximum de
refaire ses jolies ferronnerie et
d'y remettre des carreaux déboulonner la
structure de 70 m² l'emmener dans un
atelier pour la remonter entièrement le
projet des deux verdun c'est de la
refaire à neuf et à l'identique coût
total des travaux 90000 euros
ferronnerie vitrerie et maçonnerie
comprise à terme la faire servir à la
production agricole mais aussi comme
lieu de réception on veut y mettre des
plantes bien évidemment sans doute des
plantes exotiques on va y mettre des
légumes je voudrais également que cette
serre servent de lieu pour pouvoir
accueillir des événements un peu
exceptionnel mon rêve est de faire un
déjeuner en blanc sous la neige l'hiver
dîner sous les étoiles ateliers ou
encore expositions lasserre du château
de dangeau devrait servir à promouvoir
l'art de vivre à la française le couple
ignore encore le montant du financement
qu'il touchera grâce au loto du
patrimoine mais espère la rénover avant
la fin de l'année prochaine oui